hello I'm Donna Friesen we're all
missing things about the way life used
to be thousands of people of course have
lost loved ones to covet 19 and for them
life will never be the same
others are yearning for just a bit of
what life was like before the pandemic
something to lift our spirits something
to rally around sports is what does that
for millions of people Nelson Mandela
said Sports has the power to inspire the
power to unite people in a way that
little else does sports he said can
create hope where once there was only
despair we could all use some hope right
now professional sports are working out
ways to come back fans can't be there in
person but preparations are underway to
drop the first Popkin throw the first
pitch in this Kovan era Eric Sorenson
looks at how and when the games will
begin again in golf safe distance is
easy when there's no gallery expensive
fairways and golfers don't have to get
close to each other a round of golf for
charity went off without a hitch or a
coffee and so the world of sports is
getting back in the swing pandemic or
not car racing naturally separates
drivers from one another NASCAR gave us
our first look at a major North American
event in front of an empty grandstand
baseball already up and running in South
Korea can also be played with limited
contact but when European soccer kicked
off once more one thing became clear
you can't play contact sports without
the contact it looks and certainly
sounds different in a cavernous stadium
basically you have to have some
integrity to the game for sure Bob
Stella Kizza veteran of sports marketing
well there might be certainly a little
emotion missing without having fans
there but I think guys will will get
used to it
I think they'll play hard though they'll
be proud you know play for pride in a
society surrounded by a highly
infectious coronavirus the challenge is
to cocoon the players and their games
from the threat of contracting or
spreading the disease the NBA wants to
pull its gargantuans from exposed public
service to cloister the entire league at
Disney in Florida the NHL in its own way
plans to isolate in two hub cities
commissioner Gary Bettman says the
competition comes second I want to make
clear that the health and safety of our
players coaches essential support staff
in our communities are paramount health
protocols will differ but the basics are
first the outside world where kovat 19
is present a transition zone where
athletes and key officials will be
tested repeatedly and verified to be Co
vid free and then the inner sanctum
where the games are played it's hoped in
a pristine setting and close contact in
competition is allowed and justified
with full on contact something frowned
upon everywhere else is there a risk yes
but it can be managed
says this epidemiologist living with
some uncertainty and a little bit of
risk while we're in the pre vaccine era
of CO vid 19 if there is a safe way to
do it and if the public health
authorities deem that it something that
can be done safely I think it's a
completely acceptable thing to start
back up again disease specialists warned
that if the virus spreads on a team it
could force a shutdown but the aim is to
prevent that there may indeed be cases
of kovat 19 but says one NBA insider the
plan is to respond swiftly before it
spreads and carry on the NBA would then
isolate in quarantine that player
continued the daily testing protocols
they would have no stoppage of play
Bobst Elex says the league's can't allow
themselves to be paralyzed by a single
Kovan 19 case the point right now is if
someone does test positive they can't
shut the whole operation down they have
to be able to extricate that person and
isolate that person so I mean just like
everywhere else there being extra
careful what we'll be missing of course
are the fans the excitement they bring
and the billions they spend the
spectacle just one year ago
basketball diehards squished together in
Toronto no fear of contagion now it just
seems like a bygone era
[Applause]
how long will this stark new normal last
and at what cost the three most valuable
sports franchises in the country are
right here down the street at the Rogers
Center where the Toronto Blue Jays play
and here at the Scotiabank Arena the
Toronto Raptors in the Toronto Maple
Leafs now the three Toronto teams along
with the Montreal Canadiens are the only
teams in the country valued at more than
1 billion dollars so a lot of money is
at stake it's estimated that the big
leagues involved stand to lose five and
a half billion dollars because of what
happened this spring more than 3 billion
is from the fans that's the loss of
tickets and food and merchandise and the
other two billion is from TV revenue now
they may not get the fans back but there
is money to be recovered from the
television revenue one reason why they
want to come back this summer I don't
think any business model could have
anticipated this richard powers studies
sports and business he says without fans
in the stands thousands of jobs have
been lost and minor-league and amateur
sports are really suffering as the
public stops buying tickets in
communities everywhere they're very
dependent on you know literally bums and
seats there are thousands of jobs at
risk here many of those won't come back
without spectators in the seats but he
says big leagues will get by because
millions will tune in to see Connor
McDavid and Sidney Crosby or Pascal
siakam and LeBron James fight for a
championship even in the wrong season
the leagues that means they keep their
television revenues they keep their
sponsorship revenues you know they're
taking a significant hit as we mentioned
with the lack of spectators but at least
with the sponsors and the TV contracts
they can make something out of what
reappears to be nothing right now the
luckiest of the big league sports is
American football the pandemic arrived
out of season and the biggest enterprise
in all of sport plans to restart on time
in September Major League Baseball is
planning its season by playing half the
usual number of games historically a day
at the ballpark was always seen as an
escape from the bigger problems of the
world the national pastime gets on the
bandwagon
800 million dollars is the contribution
of baseball fans to the bond drive
during the Second World War a very
different crisis baseball was viewed as
indispensable to the morale of Americans
so majorly ball kept going during the
war there may not be quite that
sentimentality today but big times
sports are an important part of the
fabric of society that we're in this
together and as the Toronto Raptors
proved last year sports can unify a lot
of people around a bouncing ball sport
is a significant part of our culture and
we miss that and if we can get the
leagues going I think people will really
appreciate that it'll give them
something to look forward to and at a
time like this we need all the help we
can get to get through this this
pandemic for fans there is a rhythm and
a continuity in the sports calendar you
start the year and hockey and basketball
are in full swing you have big events
like the Super Bowl then there's curling
for some fans March Madness for others
and here comes the Masters baseball
starts the playoffs all kinds of events
start up in the spring except this year
a black hole everything disappeared
now the attempt is to begin that rhythm
again not just baseball in the
summertime or the CFL but basketball
playoffs in July the Indy 500 in August
as the NFL begins silver the Kentucky
Derby and how about the Stanley Cup in
the autumn and some sports will not
happen till next year
March Madness Wimbledon soccer's euro
championship and the Tokyo Olympics the
impact on sports will be felt for at
least another year and who knows how
soon the crowds can come back to watch
and cheer whether it's professional or
youth and amateur sports and playing the
games they will be a matter of trial and
error and risk as long as the pandemic
lasts
[Music]